my parents live in rural Indiana they
live in a town that's mostly
conservative they talked to other
conservatives on a regular basis
everybody watches Fox News you know they
share the same memes on the Internet
it didn't shock me when I heard that
they were voting for Trump but it hurt
me I have been raised to not be okay
with people like Donald Trump I've been
raised to not think I was better than
anybody else we were taught to be
cordial and not talk about religion and
politics in public and for them to
support a candidate that is so
disconnected from that that has no
respect for those qualities H shocked me
and then it went a layer deeper than
shock it shocks me that they did it and
then it disgusts me
because it makes me feel that everything
that I know is wrong how can they
believe that America is such an awful
place that the qualities that they
raised me to have they're willing to
toss up the window for this candidate I
just I can't wrap my brain around it and
so I know you know I said all this on
the phone call or whatever with my mom
and it just kind of I felt like I was
talking to a brick wall she's so
concerned about the economy and job
she's willing to like let everything
else go she's willing to let the
sexual-assault go she's willing to let
the I've got one black guy in the crowd
supporting me go she's willing to let go
the fact that he ridiculed a disabled
reporter because all she knows is that
people like her are losing their jobs
people like her are losing their
retirements people like her are losing
their health benefits and she doesn't
believe someone like Hillary Clinton can
help when I got off that phone call and
I didn't say I love you the first thing
that came to my mind is what if
something happens to my mom what if I
never get to talk to her again and you
know I texted her and I said I'm sorry
for what I said earlier I just couldn't
live with the idea of never speaking to
her again
letting politics be something that tears
our family apart and I just I didn't
want the last thing that I said to her
to be about Donald Trump I think that a
lot of liberals and a lot of
progressives see Trump supporters as
these ignorant hateful people who
know what they're doing don't know who
they're voting for have no idea what's
going on in the world and I think that
this holier-than-thou kind of
perspective that we offer to them it
shuts them out like they're not
interested in hearing what we have to
say they're not interested in meeting us
halfway because we don't understand
where they're coming from this election
was long it was exhausting it was
hurtful it was mean-spirited but I think
underneath of it all we we want the same
things as American people and if we can
just say sorry and be humble and come to
the table we can actually get something
done